la désertique c'est bien petit
provocateur c'est une allégorie poussé à
l'extrême
nous sortons de l'époque de
l'acquisition et en martinique
la tension et les et les quand même
vivre comme en europe entre protestants
et catholiques mais ici les corps
constitués quand je parle de construire
deux corps constitués je peux je pars
découverte du gouvernement et aussi du
du du clergé
ils veulent respecter les lois
françaises mais il n'arrive pas parce
que la martinique est en tout le temps
en pénurie et 90% des des capitaines de
vaisseau qui apportent la nourriture
pour la martinique pour pour pour la
caraïbe
ils sont de la religion protestante
ils sont juifs ils sont réformés donc
ils sont des hérétiques et
malheureusement le le gouvernement est
aussi le clergé est obligé de composer
avec ses ennemis
dudu du roi de france à travers ce livre
j'ai voulu montrer surtout je parle
beaucoup du dudit quartier de basse
pointe à l'époque que damas knicks
étaient sept à la société des nations
silva qui avait cette tension il y avait
certes un prêtre jésuite qui était un
tolérants vis-à-vis aider des anglicans
mais j'ai voulu montrer que la
martinique était très ouverte
lorsque l'actuel habitations gradis
avant si devant cette cette habitation
appartenir à un dénommé prune et il est
apparemment sûr que monsieur queen était
protestant est donc grand rivière et la
martinique était vraiment ouverte au
monde
nous avons des réformés
nous avons des musulmans on avait tous
il y avait une certaine tolérance
même quand l'achat de l'inquisition
étaient présentes à la martinique on
était très ouvrir l'exemple de joseph
diby est l'ancien esclave de monsieur
quinn qui devenu marin sont son patron
était juif
ils s'entendaient très bien est ce qu
est ce qui est extraordinaire
ce juif la demande à un prête de faire
le catéchisme en privé à ce jeune ancien
esclave il y avait de la tolérance et la
mardi qui est et ce qu'elle fait sourire
ce que je veux dit aussi l'histoire de
la martinique est beaucoup plus vaste
que ce territoire il soit de la
martinique est arrivé par la mer mais
malheureusement elle repart par la mer
donc il ne faut jamais écrire l'histoire
en noir et en blanc il ya toujours des
nuances beaucoup de nuances donc à cette
période de l'inquisition en martinique
il y avait beaucoup d'hypocrisie il y
avait beaucoup de dissimulateur des
juifs se faisait passer pour des
protestants des protestants se faisait
passer pour pour des catholiques et des
prêtres catholiques devenait très tôt
les ans parce qu'ils avaient faim pas de
là ne veulent pas de la nourriture
spirituelle mais du boeuf salée du
cochon salle et de la farine des olives
venant des pays musulmans les mahométans
comme il disait à l'époque